let me ask you to philosophical at a
human level what do you think about
immigration
a legal and legal immigration
from the direction of Mexico to the
United States so we have an estimated 11
million illegal immigrants in the United
States
and uh estimated 45 million legal
immigrants a few things about that when
kobet hit there was no shortages of uh
produce in the supermarkets which means
that I mean illegal immigration is
pretty much the backbone of all uh
produce and some of the farming
Industries out there you know most of it
so illegal immigration and illegal
illegal workers in those fields are
essential workers in a way
I think there's a weird relationship in
the United States with some of these
workers and how they're demonized and
how they're called criminals I think
there's
there was a state out there that passed
anti-illegal immigrant uh worker
legislation the farmers had to look
elsewhere for for people to show up to
work in some of these fields which
basically caused millions of dollars
worth of losses for some of these uh
Farms
um anywhere you go out there in the
United States you go into the kitchens
and there's going to be Paisanos there
you know French high-level French
restaurants
you'll see people from Puebla there that
uh made their way illegal and might have
legalized regularized regularized their
way into the country or or in a
sanctuary City
uh you go to the service industry hotels
you know those are the people changing
the blankets those are the people in the
washrooms you have them doing jobs that
no American wants to do realistically
and they're everywhere in this country
and they are the backbone of some of
these industries that are essential in
this country do you think there's a deep
sense in which they are American I think
they're indispensable and anybody that
says they aren't
is delusional if you take every single
legal worker out of the industry in the
United States and send them back like
there's a movie out there called like
yes in Mexican is a day without Mexicans
you know
everything would stop so the the
relationship is there uh people talk
about the history of slavery in this
country like it's a thing that's in the
past
uh there's endangered the endangered
slaves in the country right now people
that are paying off their their people
Smugglers because they brought them into
this country and they haven't been able
to pay that fine or that fee yet
and are basically being held hostage by
that here in the United States so
they're slaves right now in the United
States you know people are talking about
it's a historical context
what do we do about it how are we
supposed to think about it we're going
to have to rethink how we look at
immigration illegal or illegal or
illegal or legal immigration from Mexico
and how we view Mexico as a as a foreign
country
um your relationship to Canada is one
thing your relationship to Mexico was
another
the foreign policy towards Mexico has
been pretty nefarious in the as far as
the United States in a lot of ways you
know you can go back there was a student
Massacre during the Olympics
and the president in turn at that time
was a see just on the CIA payroll and it
was a counter communist type maneuver
that we're doing down there
but there's some bloody hands on on the
U.S side but of some of the things that
have been happening in Mexico as far as
destabilization and influencing and
meddling and foreign policy out there
most of the guns that are used down
there come from the US you know and
that's a that's another interesting
aspect and responsibility that people
should kind of think about up here so
there is on the drug war side a machine
that's fueling the drug war I mean
there's a giant drug habit up here you
know but also a governmental
intelligence and Military Support
through the sale of weapons I don't know
about to sell weapons but you know
there's some very
you talk about poorest borders uh coming
up there's poorest borders also going
down you know there's there's a flow of
guns going down and munitions
which again they don't kill anybody by
themselves you know they put the get put
in the hands of the desperate that are
trying to feed a giant drug Market
to the north you know Mexico has a
saying Mexico Mexico
far from God but close to the United
States right uh and uh there's a there's
definitely a responsibility on both
sides this is no longer a Mexico problem
a U.S problem this is a regional problem
and if we don't think of that as a
regional problem with our brothers on
the southern side of it and with family
we're we're related in blood there's
like we are we are Mexico in the United
States are like this
but it's become popular in politics they
just throw a line
right and I think we need to get to a
place where we can figure out how to
make those connections and repair some
of the Damage Done by like just years
and years of uh bad policy on both sides
of the Border policy and rhetoric the
way we talk about the way we think about
it not just the actual policy but uh
seeing the humanity and the people that
are here yeah it's an easy thing they're
coming to take our jobs is something you
hear there was a state out there that
passed them uh anti-uh
anti-legislation as far as illegal
workers on fields and it led to massive
losses nobody wanted to show up for
those jobs basically the people would
show up one day and they wouldn't come
back and they were doing jobs that
people just don't want to do
are they taking that from the locals or
are they feeling an essential role that
we feel guilty about and the rhetoric
around it is more about guilt
than anything
um I am an immigrant myself you know I
I've gone through the experience of
doing it legally and
I've seen people not do it legally and
are in way better places than I am
basically uh by going around some of the
system
um the system itself the immigration
system here in the US is this is there's
something wrong you know it's kind of
broken
um and people coming here illegally are
not only you know they're looking for a
better life for themselves a better life
for people this whole aspect of
vilifying them and they're like oh
there's the there's this immigrant did
this horrible thing this immigrant did
that horrible thing and uh people call
it saying you know go back to your
country at the same time they go to a
hotel where they're all the service
staff is from that part of the world and
they're here irregularly or they go to
the you know the Whole Foods and they
get some produce there and it's picked
by some of the same people are vilifying
again we need to kind of like
think about that and analyze that for
ourselves yeah the idea of go back to
your country and finding the other and
having a disdain and a hate towards the
other ever since I had a recent
conversation with yay formerly known as
Kanye West I got to hear a few things
from
let's say unfriendly messages from White
nationalists
and I got to learn about this world
um I continue on the Journey of learning
which is the idea that the United States
this country should look a certain way
should have a certain skin color should
have a certain religion and everything
else is a pollution is a poison to this
I made it sound hateful right now but
they usually frame it in a positive way
like the Purity I'm sure Hitler also
phrased everything in a positive way
especially in the 1930s about the purity
of Germany but the reality of the United
States and one of the things that makes
it
at least the idea of the United States
is the soup the mix unlike So Many
Nations I've I've traveled to there's
the the diversity the good kind of
diversity is what makes this country
great and uh there's so I think it's as
it needs to be based on the
accepting the different subgroups that
make up the United States versus trying
to purify it I think Mexican immigrants
is just another flavor of saying this is
the other let's reject the other yeah I
saw that interview by the way that was
that that you showed amazing restraint
and then an interview
my experience and I I came up here again
Trump was elected when I was when I came
up here so it was a weird
time for me as far as being an immigrant
in the Immigrant experience for myself
um by both being you know basically the
bad the the ones that were you know
talked about in that way and also having
a bunch of my friends who were very
conservative and you know wearing some
of those Maga hats around me and like
hey Ed like
like well I mean you know you know I'm a
guest here so I have to you know but uh
it's a balancing act is what I've been
looking at it as you know on one side
there's the woke side of it which
everything goes and then on the other
side is like let's hold on to some of
these things that make us who we are
on my end you know I want to get to a
place where I can smoke a joint uh
concealed carrier firearm be it my gay
best friend's wedding and I want the
government not to say anything about it
and I think there's Parts in the United
States here that kind of feel the same
way but there's extremes on both sides
that are pulling you to one side or the
other
and I've seen more of the United States
than most Americans I'm in a different
state every weekend so I get to go to I
going to Tampa tomorrow
then I'm going back to California then
I'm from Tennessee later then Kentucky
so I get to see all types of people and
all types of mentalities and and ways
that people live in this country is more
diverse than most would think you know
if you only see it through with the lens
of television or media
what I keep seeing out there that for me
is like a
the reason I came here I guess and a lot
of a lot of the reasons that I feel a
vested interest in this country not just
because of can my kids American so I
have a very very big interest in this
country doing well but I think I see is
the there's still the opportunity and
the ability to do something with
yourself and and opportunities out there
for people like me that come here with
nothing I came here with
an experience space
a truck
and some demons and uh yeah and a bunch
of demons in a bag and I'm here with you
talking right now about some of those
experiences to another immigrant another
to another immigrant and both of us are
reaching people out there that uh you
know might not might haven't heard a
voice of people like us that come that
come here with our own bag of uh demons
but where else in the world can two
people like us have a conversation with
a with an audience like us and not be uh
shot outside of of this because of the
stuff we're saying yeah listen to was uh
with with love and respect not
not division